the the sensors were able to pick up
heart rate variability
and is that how we know when heart
attacks occur now or
something is happening is it the heart
rate variability of the one that
yeah some sort of indication something's
wrong there's a lot of things that go
into that
um i would say early research has been
shown that basically
lowered heart rate variability you're
right you know is a very good indicator
of
a heart attack or cardiac event um now
specifically there's lots of different
cardiac events and turns out
like you're sort of getting why can we
see heart rate variability now that's a
really good question
it's really the granularity of these
sensors and i can talk about sort of why
it's a ring and why
you know how we focused on that because
there's a lot of key details in there
that are pretty technical but
would be love to dive into um you know i
think you can train these data sets on
anything
so if you can actually get that raw
pulse waveform
you can start comparing that raw pulse
waveform to an ekg
and then start looking at ekgs of hey
what do people have afib look like
well what are people who look like you
know some congestive heart failure look
like before that event
and you can start to train and you know
we even showed this with with
covid what what are people who look like
they're getting you know who've gotten
sick
look like what are what are all their
what is that pulse waveform data and
your temperature data and all the things
we derive from our respiratory rate
heart rate heart rate variability look
like
for this subset of people and you can
you can train these data sets you can
train these models against
you know reference data and sleep became
a driving force
for you raising money i understand in
the last round or
just the product evolving i saw that
also with our investment in calm
yeah when they went you know they owned
meditation but they also then started to
own
the sleep portion of that tell me about
you know
the impact sleep has had and also the
anxiety produced
during the pandemic and for many people
not all obviously some people were
thrilled uh but
you know trump's presidency here in the
united states caused a lot of anxiety
uh caused a lot of insomnia and so did
the pandemic
so i'm curious during your tenure did
you see
those things manifest in the aggregate
data
of aura's data set you must be able to
have seen
the pandemic and the shutdowns occurred
many sleepless nights tell us about what
you saw in the
aggregate data obviously you're not
looking at individuals
totally yeah so being able to see you
know
de-identified data no one's name
attached to it but across the whole
database
um yeah you know very interesting things
i think counter-intuitively when the
pandemic started
for sure um but we actually published
this on our blog the pulse
where we actually showed that um as the
pandemic went on after a couple months
people were actually getting
more consistent patterns right so
they're actually sleeping
better for most people now some people
some people
obviously we're not now wait a second
yeah think through that theory
why would people be sleeping better in a
pandemic i think well less variation
you're not going out you're not going to
work you're not going to dinner you're
not going out drinking and partying and
uh going to the movies or something like
that you're you're leading a more
sedentary
isolated lifestyle yeah consistent
right consistency so more so perhaps
even more so i was doomed scrolling till
four in the morning
god i look back at my my pandemic was a
complete
mania now we definitely saw that with a
subset
of yeah i'm in that subset of does not
go to sleep keep scrolling twitter and
looking at covet stats
now we're trying to figure it out we we
should look at it again
and in the election i want to get back
to you because we actually showed their
collective
you know loss of sleep to the us um on
that but um
on what's happening now you know we we
actually haven't gone through it lately
we should probably do it as as
it's now dragged down for every year i i
bet probably most are probably like you
now you know you were describing
yourself early on like as this is
dragged on people are getting pent up
people want to get out
and so i think you know after this much
this much isolation i wouldn't be
surprised if people's data has changed
but
it's a good reason something good and
topical to do now what we did see during
the election we actually uh you know
published this on our blog too and we
showed that i think the average american
got
45 minutes of sleep less sleep that
night you know so you start to multiply
out like you know yeah 300 million
people people are not gonna be it's
actually people are not gonna be
when people say it's not gonna be a
productive day at the office they're
right
exactly yeah so no look i think we saw
fascinating data and getting back to
sleep
you know really this idea of readiness i
think you know when we
when aura was launched at the launch
festival right no wearables were really
doing sleep
right fitbit hadn't launched sleep apple
now does time in bed but they don't
really do sleep they don't do sleep
stages they don't do
even heart rate variability consistently
um throughout the day or night
um but you know at the time no one was
really doing sleep so it's just steps
and just
active heart rate was sort of the thing
like how high can you get your heart
rate or
you know when you're running um you know
just like chest straps and yeah
i think for us you know the approach was
like hey sleeps this whole other area
of your life and by the way 99.9 of
people even investment bankers
will try to sleep tonight but only 10
percent of the us is actually going to
work out
today and maybe 15 to 20 will work out
this week now 40 percent
pay for gym memberships or pre-covet
we're paying but um sleep is a
consistent thing you do
it has an immediate impact on how you
perform and feel
physically mentally emotionally the next
day and frankly
if you look at it as a country or as a
society globally
we're getting less sleep you know
probably are we getting less sleep is it
just
it's the devices it's got to be people
taking their iphones and doom-scrolling
and playing that last game of
threes or listening to that last pocket
or you know netflix right netflix used
to say their biggest enemy
was sleep right yeah you're right you
know what man binge watching is killing
people yeah i mean it's
literally people will start thinking
about binge watching like they do social
media like it's almost like the new
cigarettes
you must get sleep to be ready for the
next day
it's worse than i think it's worse than
cigarettes you know lack of sleep has
been shown to
early onset of alzheimer's in particular
great research out there showing
less deep sleep is leading to the early
onset of alzheimer's um you know if you
get
four hours of sleep um basically your
your glycemic response your insulin
levels are going to be nearly
you know 50 percent as worse so you get
fat
you get fat so so actually the hormone
that's what was happening to you when
you became a fat
investment banker investment banker it
was because lack of sleep
yeah and there's no way there's no way
to to diet or
exercise out of that if you're you know
if your body is physiologically just not
this this one food the hunger thing and
insulin responses so i
actually more interested in that i
thought this was fascinating so you have
two
you have two hormones really that
control your hunger and then how full
you are
so so you know so grielin you know
determines sort of how hungry you feel
leptin is determining actually how full
you feel after
so if you get four hours first eight
hours of sleep your greenland levels
double and your leptin levels go down by
half
so you're going to be you're going to
crave twice as much food and you're
going to feel
half as full right so your body's
training you it's like why would you
we're the only species on earth
matt walker says is such a good point
only species on earth that self you know
deprives themselves of sleep
and so your body is like hey you're
trying to kill me or you know
something's trying to hunt me i'm like
you know so i need to eat a lot of food
right like you're going through this
fight-or-flight ah that's fascinating
yeah if you're not sleeping it's like
get more food in the system because
you're
it's probably evolutionarily that you're
being chased by a tiger or a pack
another village that wants to kill your
village or something it was it was that
cheetah he's still chasing us that was
in the room earlier